before we go we need to end on some good
vibes yes especially after that
discussion and uh you know who else is
feeling those good vibes paris hilton
and lindsay lohan yeah so paris stopped
by watch what happens live with her mom
kathy hilton and spoke about the recent
reconciliation with her old friend
lindsay lohan and i mean there's no bad
vibes here as paris revealed everything
is all good ah we'll see you tomorrow
bye the last time you said beyond on
this show it was during plea the fifth
and i asked you a shady question about
lindsay lohan and you answered shadily
but i hear that the two of you are like
in contact and buddies again is that
true i just feel that we're grown-ups
now i just got married she just got
engaged oh great we're not like in high
school like it was i think it was just
very immature and now everything is all
good i love that who was the
was the first one to to reach out to the
other
i saw that she got engaged when i was on
my honeymoon and i just said
congratulations and then and that and
that broke the ice that's great that
makes me happy